deutsche welle find out more about
what's new in medical treatments
alternative medicine as well as
nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio today is dr. michio toit he's
head of the department of preventive
medicine at the charity hospital in
berlin welcome to the show thanks dr.
toid you actually run those courses to
become a nonsmoker how likely is it that
a heavy chain smoker can really stop
smoking the success rates for smokers
after one year around twenty to thirty
percent so it's there is a chance to
become a nonsmoker if you combine
behavioral cognitive therapy with
nicotine replacement therapy or other
medical aids for example so it's about
25 to 30 percent and how much is it if
you don't do anything at all just quit
smoking yes then the success rate in in
trials is not very high you can estimate
around two to five percent will have
succeeded after one year still so most
of them will not need not succeed it's
very discouraging they're very very low
em success rates and how comes why is it
so difficult to retain from smoking well
this is dependent on the function of
nicotine in the brain and it's very
important for the reward systems so
nicotine and stimulates the brain and
those who are smoking and have very
pleasant sensations and like feeling of
relaxation better concentration so it's
very hard to let those sensations go and
become a nonsmoker but there are a lot
of products focusing on nicotine and the
withdrawal symptoms like patches or
chewing gum are they really helpful yes
so there's quite a large body of
research especially about nicotine
replacement therapy and in combination
with behavioral therapy they really help
because they give this kind of reward
feeling which is a little bit different
from the sensations you get a smoker
because the concentration of ink routine
while smoking is becoming a short time
very high and goes down and with a
nicotine replacement it's more constant
concentration not a flash it's not a
flash yes let's focus a bit on those
modern devices called e-cigarettes all
electronic cigarettes some expert really
claim that those are the revolution in
smoking well actually it sounds great
and but the problem at the moment is
that there is no research yet available
which allows us from the scientific
point of view to conclude about the
risks or the benefits of this end of
this therapy of the e-cigarette so it's
read too early to tell but what about
those pills and medications a lot of
research going on with just pills for
quitting smoking well they are beside
the nicotine replacement therapy you
have antidepressants like the book or
pre-owned and also varenicline which is
a substance which is very close to to
nicotine and one can generally say that
replacement therapy or medical help
doubles the success chance and but it
should always be combined also with
psychological help cognitive behavioral
therapy or hypnotherapy dr. todd how
important is motivation for quitting to
smokin motivation is very important most
people that want to quit smoking are in
a state of ambivalence meaning that they
are balancing the pros and cons of
stained smoker or quitting very helpful
for this decision is focusing on the
future on what you will gain if you are
a nonsmoker and like what kind of body
sensations you may have when you do
sports and what kind of possibilities
there are new arising and also on the
freedom you will have
from from the habit of smoking and
buying cigarettes so let's bet
behavioral therapies yes sir we got a
view question from Serbian Evan also
gonna [ __ ] wants to know are there any
special tricks which can kick him into
being a nonsmoker yes so M the first
point is really decide we determined are
non-smoking and try to decide in this
situation for the way of becoming a
nonsmoker focus on the future and then
and be prepared for the situations where
you usually start smoking so try to
imagine visualize what else you could do
in these situations be prepared and then
be successful with it so those are the
traps if you go to a party and usually
your party smoker you start to smoke
again are there any tricks not to fall
into those traps yes you have to be
prepared internally so in the cognitive
behavioral therapy but also on the
hypnotherapy in the hypnotherapy you
really go into the situations and
visualize them and try to find out
different situations and different
strategies and if you have really
anchored them in your subconscious than
usually it works and this is how hard
gnosis works or are there any other
methods in hypnosis yes and who can all
this you use and the state of deep
relaxation and drones to find out and to
develop the strategies you go into the
situations in your imagination and
cognitive behavioral therapy you usually
do is just with with a cognitive
strategy bye-bye talking bye-bye
thinking about it many of my patients
come and visit me and want to quit
smoking a very scared of gaining weight
after quitting to smoke are there any
solutions for that that people just
don't get fat after a quit smoking yes
usually people gain weight that's a
common problem because they need some
different kind of reward and they start
eating and eating this gives also very
good sensations usually so you can go
into this eating sensations and also
find different
illusions my patience for example they
very often to sports and they have the
pleasure and the good sensations from
from doing sports others for example
have a kind of T Richard drink different
kind of teas and so you have to find a
kind of good replacement but most
important you also have to have the
humor so it's quite common that you gain
a few kills or white so you just have to
accept it that you will look differently
but you're healthy afterwards yes thanks
so much for being with us in the studio
thank you